all your life you get to make your own
choices right then all of a sudden you
get a terminal illness and the FDA is
trying to tell you what you can and
cannot do and we are trying to change
that so that the patient has the right
if there is an experimental drug out
there and I am already dying that I have
the choice to have access to that
medication basically if any state passes
a right to try law the Senate and the
House bills protect those bills from
being interfered with by any federal
agency so it basically tells the FDA to
get out of the way so people can access
the treatments they need most ALS
patients don't have five years most
don't have two years right now as an als
patient I have no hope
when my symptoms are today was mentally
diagnosed with ALS for which there's
really no effective treatment right now
this bill gets passed any drug that's
made it through a phase 1 safety trial
has been proven safe is in an active FDA
trial that I could work with my doctor
in my position to do individual trials
on it they sell my patient profile on my
own personal biomarkers the purpose of
this constitution is to protect our
rights and right now the government
stands in the way of people doing
everything possible to save their own
life